rectangular fields three by 25 so that's
our starting point let's draw that get
your ruler out
look this is seven so to you know
to prove to you how important it is to
get your ruler out okay i'll even get
this nasty spider
you know infested ruler out and let's
let's draw this thing
now it doesn't have to be the scale okay
but it should be roughly proportionate
like i should be able to look at that
and think this is not ridiculous
okay so i just heard the question
how big is it supposed to be which is an
excellent question
now being that you've been given a very
limited space to work with
okay obviously it can't be huge i draw
the line at
it's too small if you can't write on
there any of the information that you
need to say about it
okay so for example i'll show you what i
mean here's my retainer
it's 3x25 okay so as you can see my
scale is off so i might even say not to
scale
okay but clearly one of them is three
and one of them 25 right
so i'm going to put that on there i'm
gonna say this here
this is three meters okay and then the
crossways
i've got 25 now yes question
right numbers on um inside or the
outside okay now good question
now usually we would write the numbers
on the outside that's sort of the
ordinary way to do it
the reason why i know it's probably in
this case a better way to do it on the
inside
is because i've read the rest of the
question and it says it's surrounded by
a concrete path
that's one meter wide okay so i'm going
to have to put some stuff around this
and
if i put them the length measurements
there it sort of get in the way
so that's why i've done that okay you
don't have to but i think it's a little
neater
now what was i saying your diagram is
too small
if you can't write this stuff inside
your diagram right if there's no space
in there you're like i can't fit three
meters
then you need to draw that thing big up
okay so there you go there's that path
then it's surrounded sorry that field
it's surrounded by a concrete path one
meter wide so we're going to go all the
way around
so let's do this
okay it's not beautiful but it'll do
okay
um not necessary but it's nice if you
sort of show that
this thing on the outside is different
in some way so i just
shaded mine a little bit so that i could
distinguish between the field and the
path that's all
okay now since i've added on this extra
distance right
this 25 and this three don't apply to
the bigger rectangle okay
so we actually have different distances
around the outside
for instance three up and down here
but how wide is the path on the top and
the bottom it's one meter up
and one minute down right so that three
is going to become
five right so
that distance there five meters okay
exactly the same way across
the top
can you see why it's actually going to
be 27. you see why 27.
it's 25 plus one on this side and one on
that side so 25 plus 2
gives you 27. there you go
okay now you didn't have to have every
single piece of information there to get
the mark but
like why do you draw a diagram the
diagram is to help you
right it's going to make the next part
of the question so much easier to work
out
the next part of the question says find
the area
of the path now by the way this is why
that shading business was not
necessary at all but it really does help
you work out what the problem is
okay if we want to work out that blue
area right you've got your big rectangle
that's all the way around the edges
and you want to take away this inside
rectangle the white one
right and you know how to work out the
area of rectangles so i would
set it out like this this is how you
should write it underneath your diagram
okay now we tend to say a for area right
but try to be a little more specific
there's all these different areas here
right so i'll go
area of the path okay
so i put that path um the technical word
is just a subscript so it's just
underneath
that's what sub means okay now i said
it's the big rectangle
what's the area of the big rectangle
it's is it yeah that's the big rectangle
not the bigger table yeah so i said
what's the area the big rectangle
because that's the one i have to work
i then want to take away that inside
rectangle that's the white one you guys
are talking about
so shouldn't that be t minus i don't
know okay what's your question yeah um
i had a question mark here because i
worked out the inside ones not the
outside
yep um so what do i get
i'll have a look at it in a sec maybe
you can i'll put the marking guidelines
on here in a second so you can judge
but let me let me finish the working and
then you'll see okay
now again i keep on saying this right
there's all kinds of things you don't
have to do but they're a great idea
that's why i put them on the working out
so i'm going to put these in brackets
here
okay which you don't have to do but it
makes it clearer what's going on
all right what's 5 by 27
can we work it out do it in bits what's
5 times 20
100 hundred what's five times seven
thirty-five
thirty-five so it's 135.
three by twenty-five you go twenty-five
fifty
seventy-five twenty-five okay so then
that gives you you do that subtraction
that's 60 isn't it
that's 60.
now the question was where where do we
like what do i get
if i put this amount of working okay
well i think we already established
that your diagram if it's reasonable
that gets that one bar
okay bless you now the second mark is
for this line
okay now you need to have the whole line
what are we testing here
what's actually being assessed what i'm
looking for
is to see that you understand how to
convert a diagram
and get the useful bits out of it in
terms of numbers
okay so you can see what kinds of things
are going on there number one you need
to know
the area of a rectangle okay number two
bless you you've got to know there's two
rectangles
right number three
you've got to know to subtract one from
the other so i'm looking for all of
those things in that whole mark
okay so for instance if all you've got
is
like that inside rectangle okay
what have you demonstrated you
demonstrate you know what the area of a
rectangle is
and that's good but i'm looking for more
than that for this one mark
okay i kind of think about it like high
jump and high jump
you've got the bar set there and like
can i jump 150 centimeters
or not and i'm pretty bad right so
it doesn't matter how close i get to 150
if i don't get
over the bar i don't i don't get it
right so it's it's yes or no in a real
sense
last month here how would you explain
how would you describe what that last
mark is about
like obviously it's one mark for that
answer but what is someone demonstrating
that they
understand when they go from here to
here
yeah okay so number one
i'm looking for these units that's
really important what i said
if you said 60 meters then that's wrong
there's a misunderstanding there so
number one i want the square
what else like i mean i want you to try
and picture
if someone can get this line but they
can't get this loan
what's going on people did people got
this far but they didn't get there
what's the difference between those two
students apart from units like suppose
they couldn't get the 60 they got some
other nominations
yeah there's something going on in here
they've done their arithmetic role
right or they've stuck into their
calculator incorrectly okay
so that's the difference that's the
evaluation okay so there's the third
mark and that's how you set it up